et nous allons commencer notre audition
auditions de l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur et christophe castaner qui
est accompagné par son collaborateur
pierre noël clausade les excuses du prêt
misé en 1011 président de la commission
des affaires sociales et de cette
commission denquête qui est retenu sur
son département
l'objectif je le rappelle de cette
audition est d'éclairer la commission
sur le pilotage national et territorial
de la crise sanitaire sur l'action du
ministère de l'intérieur dans la gestion
de cette crise lorsque vous étiez en
fonction mais aussi sur la façon dont il
a fait face
notamment en tant qu'employeur par
rapport à cette épidémie
et puis des questions spécifiques
viendront sans doute en tout cas sur la
question des contrôles aux frontières
puisque le bureau de la commission a
effectué un déplacement à roissy il y a
quelques jours alors il est de tradition
dans ces auditions de donner la parole à
notre invité pendant cinq six minutes de
façon à faire un propos liminaire pour
ensuite passer les rapports la parole
aux rapporteurs et à l'ensemble nos
collègues ensuite
mais avant il s'agit comme nous sommes
dans une commission denquête vous
rappeler que tout propos mensongers
susceptible d'une amende de 75 mille
euros et/ou d'une peine d'emprisonnement
pouvant aller jusqu'à 5 ans et je vais
vous demander de prêter serment en
disant la vérité rien que la vérité et
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure je jure monsieur le président
merci
eh bien écoutez sans plus attendre je
vous passe la parole pour le propos
liminaire
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs cette audition intervient pour
ce qui me concerne à un moment
particulier mais surtout dans le cadre
de la crise sanitaire que nous vivons
depuis le premier trimestre de cette
année et qui a demandé une réponse
de l'état mais que les sanitaires dont
chacun sait ici qu'elle n'est pas
terminée et un moment particulier pour
ce qui me concerne parce que je ne suis
plus aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé
ministre de l'intérieur je suis redevenu
député député des
alpes-de-haute-provence et si je suis
devant vous évidemment comme ancien
ministre de l'intérieur je répondrai
avec les moyens qui sont dorénavant les
miens et qui ne sont pas ceux du
ministre de l'intérieur avec la capacité
de mobiliser les services pour répondre
à l'ensemble des questions que
pourraient avoir et nous serons peut
être amenés du coup a sollicité en
parallèle les uns et les autres le
ministère de l'intérieur pour plus de
précisions si cela vous apparaissez
nécessaire ce que je sais monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs c'est que depuis le début de
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 le gouvernement
a agi en prenant des décisions fortes
guider et c'est une particularité dans
cette gestion de crise par l'avis des
médecins des experts des décisions qui
n'ont eu qu'un seul et unique objectif
préserver la santé des français donc
pour cela préserver notre système de
soins je répondrai évidemment dans
quelques instants à vos interrogations
mais je souhaitais en quelques mots
faire un premier bilan de la période que
nous avons vécu d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur la manière dont s'est
construite la réponse de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
coordonnées ferme cette réponse suivez
les orientations fixées par le président
la république en particulier lors des
conseils de défense et de sécurité
nationale à la lumière toujours des
recommandations du conseil scientifique
placée auprès du chef de l'état sous
l'autorité unique du premier ministre
cette réponse reposer sur trois piliers
tout d'abord le centre de crise
sanitaire du ministère des solidarités
de la santé qui est en charge du
pilotage qui était en charge mais qu'il
est toujours du pilotage concernant la
réponse sanitaire à la crise ensuite le
centre de crise du ministère des
affaires étrangères chargée notamment du
lien avec les français de l'étranger
enfin il y à vous le savez au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur la cellule
interministérielle de crise la cic et
cette cellule fonctionne et n'existent
qu'au service des décisions prises par
le premier ministre et sous sa seule
autorité
même si elle est placée au ministère de
l'intérieur et c'est pourquoi elle
rassemble d'ailleurs en son sein dans
ses différentes réunions quotidiennes
tous les ministères concernés par la
crise et par cette crise en particulier
pour le volet non sanitaires de la
gestion de crise et donc au sein de la
cic dans ses différentes formations que
les décisions sont préparés que herbie
trash sont pris par le directeur de
cabinet du premier ministre
la cic assurer la transmission de ses
décisions aux administrations concernées
et notamment au préfet qui sont dans
chaque département en charge de
coordonner notre action je reviendrai
sur le rôle qui était le mien parce
qu'au fond j'assurais pour ma part le
lien avec les préfets au sein de la cic
dans une réunion quasi quotidiennes dès
son installation le 17 mars
je les informe et non seulement des
décisions prises en les expliquant mais
je vais y est aussi à recueillir leurs
observations afin de mieux appréhender
les problèmes qui se posent sur le
territoire et vous le savez nous avons
agi décidé de façon empirique et
adaptées au fur et à mesure de ce qu'ils
remontaient en termes de perception et
de capacité à mettre en oeuvre sur le
territoire
nos décisions et on a su s'adapter dans
ce dialogue permanent entre la cic les
préfets et les collectivités locales
j'aurais certainement des questions qui
me permettront de développer cela il
était pour nous essentiel de construire
cela comme une démarche proactive parce
que c'était l'assurance que le musée
reprise soit applicable qu'elle soit
appliquée et si nécessaire et c'est
arrivé très souvent corriger pour tenir
compte des circus des circonstances
propres au plus près de nos concitoyens
au niveau de la cic il ya eu jusqu'à 72
agents 72 agents qui étaient issus de
dix ministères différents et la cic est
organisé en différentes cellules suivant
l'organisation classique des cellules de
crise situation anticipation logistique
communication et décision par ailleurs
en plus de ces cellules habituel une
cellule dite thématique
interministérielle a été créé dès la
première semaine de confinement afin de
permettre quotidiennement de trancher
des questions complexes et touchant
plusieurs ministères ce système vous le
savez a déjà fait ses preuves mais dans
des circonstances différentes notamment
sur la temporalité
mais il avait mis en place par exemple
sur les attentats de 2015 ou là ou lors
des graves intempéries qui avaient
affecté saint martin et saint barthélémy
il permet ce système une coordination
efficace j'ai pu en être témoin des
services de l'état une réponse rapide
aux enjeux que nous rencontrons je vais
ajouter que la cic a déployé un certain
nombre d'outils pour nous permettre de
mieux aborder la crise annie
terre une plate forme par exemple pour
les acteurs étatiques de cette crise
ainsi été créés mais aussi des outils
pour permettre au contrôle parlementaire
sur les décisions prises dans le cadre
de l'état d'urgence avec une
communication numérique de l'ensemble
des décisions qui étaient prises à
destination du président du sénat comme
du président de l'assemblée nationale
par ailleurs mesdames messieurs monsieur
le président j'ai gardé la plus grande
attention permanente ce qui est à côté
du contrôle parlementaire un dialogue
constant qu'ils soient organisées par
les préfets sur les territoires avec les
parlementaires députés et sénateurs pour
faire en sorte que nous puissions sur
ces sujets là encore donner le maximum
d'informations pour partager non pas la
contrainte mais pour partager
l'information et la remontée
d'informations pour adapter nos
décisions voilà pour l'organisation de
cette cic je voudrais évoquer rapidement
parce que j'ai vu que c'était questions
sur lequel vous avez beaucoup travaillé
et vous donner mon regard sur la
gouvernance territoriale de la gestion
de cette crise qui a bouleversé nos
quotidiens de vente et une réponse forte
de l'état mais aussi et vous le savez
ici au sénat mieux que d'autres encore
une réponse coordonnée de l'état et des
collectivités territoriales
dès les premières heures de la crise
sanitaire j'ai souhaité que les
collectivités les maires en particulier
soient associés à notre travail par
l'intermédiaire des réunions que je
présidais quotidiennement avec les
préfets de région j'étais en contact
régulier avec les élus locaux
j'ai pu mesurer leurs inquiétudes leurs
attentes mais aussi et j'insiste sur ce
sujet leur volonté de faire évidemment
leur mobilisation totale pendant toute
cette période soit d'initiative soit aux
côtés des représentants de l'état des
tas de gens cents l'état d'urgence
sanitaire vous savez habilité
essentiellement le premier ministre le
ministre chargé de la santé et au plan
local les préfets pour prendre les
mesures utiles pour faire face à
l'urgence sanitaire
pour autant les autorités investi des
pouvoirs de police générale et je veux
parler des mères étaient en capacité
avec les instruments dont il dispose et
de compléter ce dispositif
c'est ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'arrêtés ont pu être pris à la demande
des maires qu'il s'agisse de couvre-feu
ou d'interdiction d'accès je pense par
exemple à la dans les premières
décisions à l'addition de fermeture de
la promenade des anglais à nice ou alors
la fermeture des berges de la seine à
paris
ce sont quelques exemples que j'évoque
parce qu'ils ont été particulièrement
médiatisée mais en réalité un peu
partout en france des arrêtés de ce type
ont pu être pris grâce au travail
conjoint entre les préfets et les maires
il en a été de même pour les ouvertures
dérogatoire de marché pour lequel
j'avais demandé aux préfets de veiller à
tenir compte de l'avis des maires et la
même démarche aussi avait été mise en
place pour anticiper les difficultés
dans le domaine de la gestion des
cimetières où les préférons travailler
en lien étroit avec le maire
j'ai fait ce choix et je le revendique
en termes de management de cette gestion
de crise de demander au préfet
d'accompagner les maires dans leurs
démarches pour que dans le respect du
droit évidemment nous puissions traiter
de manière la plus efficace possible les
différents sujets c'est une décision qui
me semblait naturel car c'est bien au
niveau local que l'on connaît mieux le
situation et les risques de locaux c'est
d'abord une conviction déficience c'est
d'une conviction personnelle j'étais
mère d'une petite sous préfecture des
alpes de haute provence pendant 16 ans
et c'est une conviction qui évidemment
j'ai conservé intactes quand j'étais
ministre de l'intérieur et qui m'habite
évidemment comme élu député aujourd'hui
cette relation préfet maire
particulièrement intense et efficace
lors de la période de confinement a été
tout aussi si ce n'est plus encore
importantes et nécessaires pour réussir
le déconfinement le déconfinement
obéissent à une stratégie claire la
réouverture progressive prudente et
vigilante du pays nous avions comme
objectif déjà de retrouver la vie la
plus normale possible en prenant notre
temps pour être certain que la
circulation du virus que le confinement
est bien réussi à contenir ne puisse pas
reprendre ne s'agissait donc pas de tour
ouvrir d'un coup mais d'avancer en
tenant compte de la situation sanitaire
au départ certaines restrictions étaient
maintenus dans les déplacements par
exemple mais vous l'avez bien en tête
nous avons aussi adopté alors une
stratégie territorialisée qui a fait ses
preuves en ajustant les mesures prises
et la vitesse du déconfinement en
fonction des indicateurs dont nous
disposions dès le 6 mai le premier sera
demandé dans une circulaire aux préfets
et aux directeurs généraux des ars de
s'appuyer systématiquement sur les élus
locaux
nous avons également souhaité
institutions et ce dialogue par
la création de comités locaux de lever
de confinement pouvant réunir suivant
les sujets l'état les collectivités
locales les acteurs économiques les
acteurs sociaux j'ai pour ma part
également veiller à ce que les
parlementaires soient tenus informés
régulièrement par les préfets invitant
d'ailleurs très régulièrement ces
derniers à tenir des boucles des changes
avec les parlementaires de leur
département et pendant cette période où
j'avais organisé des conférences zoom
aussi avec les élus les maires j'ai
toujours veillé à interroger des acteurs
locaux pour être sûr que les préfets
n'avaient pas oublié cette instruction
que j'avais pu leur donner et le fait
que le préfet sache que je pouvais
vérifier cela a contribué je crois à une
vraie efficacité de ces échanges là mais
vous pourrez en témoigner ou contester
la réalité sur le terrain
ensuite nous avons six travail en
faisant évoluer le cadre réglementaire
de l'état d'urgence sanitaire et nous
avons voulu dans ce cadre là nous le
gouvernement que les préfets continue à
travailler étroitement avec les
collectivités locales pour toutes les
questions locales
c'est ainsi que nous sommes inspirés de
la règle qui s'appliquait pour les
marchés afin d'organiser la réouverture
des plages des lacs ou des bases
nautiques et nous l'avons fait du coup à
la demande des maires et quand un
certain nombre de règles pouvaient être
respectés c'est le même principe durant
la phase 1 du déconfinement et c'est
après avis du maire que les préfets ont
pu autoriser l'ouverture de certains
musées certains monuments ou certains os
c'est également après l'avis des maires
que les préfets auront pu interdire
quand les caractéristiques de ces lieux
de commerce ou de vilains poser au vu de
la doctrine sanitaire l'ouverture de
certains marchés où certains centres
commerciaux de plus de 48 mètres carrés
durant la période de déconfinement
l'action du ministère de l'intérieur
s'est concentrée sur trois aspects
veiller au bon respect des mesures
décidées je pense par exemple à la
limitation des déplacements de plus de
100 kilomètres dans un premier temps
continuer à coordonner l'action des
différents services de l'état je pense
par exemple à l'action du ministère pour
assurer la logistique de l'arrivée des
masques ou encore de l'aide apportée par
les préfectures aux plus petites
communes qui n'avaient pas pu acheter de
masques et enfin préparer ainsi aussi
l'organisation ou non des élections
municipales puisque nous devions nous
tenir prêts face à tous les cas de
figure la céiste jeudi ou non en
fonction d'eux des élections qui avaient
été validées
le premier tour la cic a ensuite évolué
dans sa forme elle a déménagé dans de
nouveaux locaux toujours au sein du
ministère de l'intérieur et la conserver
sa vocation d'instance de décision avec
des représentants de tous les ministères
au meilleur niveau mais pas avec la même
intensité
la même régularité la même urgence que
celle que nous avons connue avant le
confinement et pendant le confinement je
vais ajouter également que j'ai continué
à me des échanges extrêmement régulier
avec les préfets de région et les
préfets de département afin d'assurer un
pilotage toujours au plus près du
terrain
enfin monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs permettez moi
pour conclure de revenir sur l'action
des forces de sécurité intérieure
pendant cette crise pour faire respecter
la règle du confinement nous avons
déployé 100 mille policiers et gendarmes
partout sur le territoire afin qu'ils
puissent contrôler et verbaliser quand
c'était nécessaire les contrevenants je
vais vous dire que les contrôles se sont
déployés partout sans aucune exception
la mission des forces de l'ordre a été
d'autant plus exigeante que les lutte
contre la délinquance ou contre le
terrorisme n'ont pas connu de pause le
drame qui est survenu le 4 avril à
romans-sur-isère nous le rappelle ce fut
un attentat terroriste
et je voudrais dire ici une nouvelle
fois toute l'admiration qui était la
mienne et qui demeure la mienne alors
que j'ai quitté mes fonctions sur leur
engagement constant
nous avons pendant cette période veiller
à organiser leur temps de travail si
c'est un sujet qui vous intéresse je
pourrais revenir sur ce sujet là pour
garantir à la fois la permanence pour
certains chefs de pôles et la capacité
d'intervenir en cas d'épidémie de vide
mais pour faire en sorte qu'on puisse
couvrir l'intégralité du territoire 24
heures sur 24 par une présence policière
ou une présence de gendarmerie voilà
monsieur le président je n'ai pas voulu
être trop long dans son propos liminaire
je vais donc m'arrêter ici beaucoup
d'autres sujet pourrait être abordé
et je suis sûr que nos échanges seront
l'occasion
je vous remercie je me tiens à votre
disposition et je vous précise que je
répondrai en fonction des éléments qui
sont à ma disposition aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas forcément les mêmes que ceux
dont je disposais quand j'étais ministre
de l'intérieur malgré l'accompagnement
mon collaborateur parlementaire
merci monsieur le ministre si lui vers
millet
les premières questions merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur le ministre
pour cet exposé liminaire j'aurai deux
questions brèves et précise bien sûr
vous n'êtes plus ministre de l'intérieur
je pense que vous avez été parfaitement
confronté à ces deux points la première
vous avez parlé de la gouvernance
territoriale l'instruction selon
laquelle les maires devaient être
associé à vos travaux et l'appui
systématique sur les élus locaux alors
un premier problème concerne les les
commandes de masques faites par les
régions région grand est et région de
bourgogne franche comté
ces commandes ont été livrés à
l'aéroport de bâle-mulhouse les 2 avril
et les 6 avril et l'état a saisi ses
commandes de masques
alors certes nous étions dans une
dispositif de guerre comme le président
de la république l'a dit mais si les
collectivités avaient commandé des
masques
ces masques étaient destinés en priorité
aux personnels des ehpad aux patients
dans les ehpad au personnel des
collectivités et
on peut quand même penser que ces
masques
relever d'un emploi tout à fait indiquée
alors voilà est-ce que vous avez ordonné
cette saisie de masquer ce que vous avez
validé cette action et si c'était à
refaire est ce que est ce que c'est
ainsi qu'il faudrait que ça se
reproduise j'ai pu constater lors de
l'audition des élus d'ile-de-france que
la même opération ne s'était pas
produite c'est à dire que les commandes
de la région d'île de france n'avait pas
été saisie par par la rs par l'état
deuxième point la concerne en
ile-de-france et parce que effectivement
il nous a semblé au travers des
auditions que il y avait eu une si na
une synergie assez exemplaire en ile de
france
pourquoi est-ce que vous ne parvenez pas
à vous entendre avec madame le maire de
paris sur la réouverture des parcs et
des jardins
merci monsieur le ministre c'est à vous
d'abord il ya eu une exception sur la
révision des masques une seule à
l'aéroport de bâle mulhouse j'ai eu
l'occasion de l'évoquer devant votre
assemblée lors des questions d'actualité
au gouvernement ou dans d'autres
instances notamment une audition par la
commission en charge des collectivités
territoriales mais globalement à chaque
fois que nécessaire et beaucoup plus
tard d'ailleurs parce que les commandes
de masques par les collectivités locales
sont arrivés nettement plus tard par
rapport au début de la gestion de la
crise ça s'est fait en parfaite
cohérence coordination entre les préfets
de région
les ars et les présidents tous
présidents de région mais aussi dans
certains départements sans difficulté
sur bâle mulhouse il ya une décision qui
ne relevaient pas du ministère de
l'intérieur puis je vous rappeler que ça
n'était pas dans nos compétences sur les
réquisitions ça relevait du ministère de
la santé
le préfet pouvant agir pour le compte du
ministère de la santé et j'ai eu
l'occasion d'évoquer une maladresse sur
la forme notamment parce qu'il y avait
pas eu des changes avant la mise en
oeuvre opérationnelle de d'un procès ce
qui s'approche de la réquisition est
donc j'avais reconnu cela et d'ailleurs
je vais présenter devant votre assemblée
des excuses au nom de l'état même si
c'était pas directement mon ministère
qui était à la manoeuvre sur ce sujet
mais l'idée était la suivante il ya eu
la volonté de faire une affectation
prioritaire des masques est organisé par
l'état au profit de ce que nous
considérions qui en avions le plus
besoin
les personnels de santé et savaient que
nous étions sur un type de masque dans
une carence que vous connaissez sur le
grand test et le directeur de la rs de
l'époque qui étaient dans cette
situation de difficulté pour les
personnels hospitaliers a vu passer
l'opportunité d'utiliser les masques qui
étaient là et n'a pas fait la démarche
de dialogue qui aurait pu être
nécessaire et qui à mon avis aurait
permis d'éviter la forme de la
réquisition avec les collectivités
locales
l'idée je le réaffirme c'était
évidemment le pouvoir de réquisition
existent et permettait à l'état de
prioriser la satisfaction des soignants
et des malades parmi les différents
publics étaient concernés et au fond de
mémoire mais je parle sous le contrôle
d'expression que j'ai déjà eu sur ce
sujet pour avoir en tête que en réalité
il ya eu nos nombreuses qu'au monde qui
a eu des intermédiaires qui quelquefois
ont pris des commandes sur des nombres
bien au delà de ce qui arrivait et
chaque collectivité locale pensait que
les x centaines de milliers ou les x
millions de masques qui était là c'était
les siens alors qu'en fait on était sur
une séquence de livraison
quoi qu'il en soit sur ce premier sujet
la forme de la saisie de masquer son
dialogue
à mon avis était à minima une maladresse
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire je le
redis ici parce que je pense qu'elle
aurait pu se faire dans le dialogue mais
j'ai toujours été totalement solidaire
de la décision qui avait été prise par
la préfète et par le directeur de la sse
parce que je savais que leur seul
objectif était celui de garantir au
personnel soignant particulièrement
exposés le fait de pouvoir disposer des
masques dans la carence mondiale que
nous connaissons et à ce moment de
carence mondiale que nous avons connue
sur la réouverture en ile-de-france des
parcs et jardins
il faut assumer qu'il ya eu des
décisions qui ont été prises à base de
recommandations des professionnels de
santé sur ces sujets et qui avait un
désaccord
la mairie de paris voulait une
réouverture rapide des parcs et jardins
quand les recommandations du conseil
scientifique était
parce que chacun la mémoire de ce qui se
passe dans les parcs et jardins
quand ils sont ouverts dans ces moments
là et qu'il fait beau avec une densité
de population extrêmement forte et donc
du coup il y avait une recommandation
qui consistait à ne pas rouvrir les
parcs et jardins parce qu'on savait que
ça suscite et un attrait de population
au fort à un moment donné sur une base
concentré alors vous me direz on les a
eus ailleurs en particulier sur les
invalides et en particulier sur le canal
saint martin mais même au delà partout
il y avait des capacités de
rassemblement
mais même quand tous les parcs et
jardins sont ouverts je peux facilement
vous trouver sur internet des photos
vous verrez certain nombre de parcs
parisiens sur lequel vous avez une
densité très forte de population donc le
choix stratégique qui a été fait c'était
celui de ne pas ouvrir les parcs et
jardins le plus longtemps possible pour
éviter qu on est justement un afflux de
population et du coup une propagation du
virus sur cette population qui ne
respectaient pas forcément les gestes
barrière dans ce cadre là il ya une
discussion politique sur ce sujet il ya
eu des pressions politiques sur ce sujet
mais le premier ministre doit philippe a
souhaité effectivement que nous
puissions limiter au maximum les
rassemblements dans ce cadre là il nous
savions quand les rouvrant nous pouvions
susciter des rassemblements qui était au
fond assez réduit j'ai en tête les
invalides mais qui était sur paris assez
réduit avant que nous ouvrions les parcs
quand même une précision à apporter par
rapport à ce processus de réquisition
parce que nous avions compris me
semble-t-il à travers des auditions des
responsables du ministère de la santé
que c'était de la responsabilité de
l'intérieur que de réquisitionner ces
masques
en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai
véritablement cru comprendre c'est pas
forcément une logique qui peuvent dire
voilà il ya un besoin impératif de
masques pour les professionnels de santé
débrouillez-vous si je puis m'exprimer
ainsi pour prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour qu'on ait ces masques
il appartient à ce moment là au
ministère de l'intérieur de prendre ses
réquisitions
on a eu l'impression qu'on se
renvoyaient un petit peu la balle en
tout cas c'est ce que j'ai ressenti et
voilà qui fait quoi on n'arrive pas à le
savoir de façon précise donc essayer
d'être un peu plus précis si vous le
pouvez monsieur le ministre
et puis nous dira également qu'elle ait
été le volume de masques qu'ils aient pu
être ainsi récupérer à travers ces
décision de réquisition je vais après
comment précis monsieur le président je
pense que nous devons appliquer la loi
avec les préfets sont là pour appliquer
la loi je le dis dans mon propos
liminaire des gens qui était en
responsabilité c'était le premier
ministre le ministre de la santé ou les
préfets mais par compétences déléguées
par du ministre de la santé
je ne dis pas ça pour me défausser j'ai
moi même assumé de répondre aux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
aux sénateurs sur ce sujet je suis
totalement solidaire de cette décision
je le précisais et en droit le ministère
de l'intérieur n'avait pas à décider
n'avait pas la capacité juridique a
décidé de ses réquisitions mais vous
vous demanderez d'être prêt fille précis
je vais partir des faits le dimanche 5
avril nous avons été informés le
ministère de l'intérieur des difficultés
qui s'étaient posés par cette décision
prise par le préfet du haut rhin
sur proposition de l'agencé régionale de
santé d'allouer prioritairement la
livraison des masques qui étaient
importés de chine
dans ce cadre la halle agences
régionales de santé du grand est
voilà la réalité et sur la situation
c'était une situation de tensions
hospitalières que vous connaissez ce la
région du conte est l'importateur avait
assuré le vendredi 3 avril qu'il est en
mesure de livrer la totalité de la
commande restantes soit 4 millions de
masques la livraison de la cargaison de
cet importateur l'aéroport de bâle
mulhouse le dimanche 5 avril a donc sur
ces bases light orienté au profit des
soignants et des malades de la région
sur le volume annoncé par l'importateur
2 mai - d'autres de mémoire voilà je
vous parlais de mémoire au fond après
que je vous ai dit que c'était
juridiquement placé sous l'autorité du
ministère de la santé
mais évidemment le miz intérieur par
lasser préfet jeudi que je
quotidiennement on en parlait après
cette tension là parce que je trouve que
ça n'était pas la bonne façon de
procéder je parle pas juridiquement je
parle politiquement dans la relation
avec les collectivités locales
j'ai indiqué au préfet que je souhaitais
qu'on soit beaucoup plus dans le
dialogue et j'en ai jamais dans la
décision préventive sans le dialogue
donc je pense qu'il n'y a pas eu
d'autres tensions que celle ci qui a été
médiatisé sur laquelle j'ai eu
l'occasion de répondre je crois même que
le premier ministre aussi avait eu
l'occasion de répondre sur ce sujet je
ne suis pas sûr de ma réponse mais de
mémoire ses deux seuls dossiers de qui a
pris la forme de réquisition que j'ai en
tête
ensuite dans chaque région nous avions
évité avec le ministre l'idée verront
les préfets à dialoguer avec les
présidents de région parce que le choix
que nous avons fait et celui de deux
d'élargir au maximum la capacité de
récupération de masques et donc d'avoir
un dialogue avec les régions pour dire
idéologique ou en gardienne par une
partie pour votre personnel pour les
collectivités locales mais la priorité
doit être déterminé avec la rs et je
crois qu'il ya peu de régions où ça
s'est mal passé
merci catherine des roches
oui merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur ministre ment je vais poser ma
première question en regard de ce que
vous venez de dire sur les réquisitions
vous aviez donné les instructions si je
puis dire au préfet dans le dialogue et
dans la formation et dans la
transparence vis-à-vis des des élus
locaux notamment où des élus nationaux
ça a été le cas dans beaucoup de
départements ça a été le cas dans mon
département où vraiment les relations
étaient très étroites
dans ce que vous venez de nous dire en
fait c'était la rs qui décide des de la
réquisition et du besoin en masse et le
préfet faisait en sorte que que ce soit
le cas justement lorsqu'on a entendu les
acteurs de terrain on a vu dans certains
départements les relations préfère ars
étaient fluides et se passait bien mais
que dans d'autres c'est cette double
autorité si je puis dire le préfet d'un
côté les ars de l'autre qui disait on
préfère indépendante vous a posé
problème
quel est votre regard vous sur ce ce qui
a pu être vécu comme ça et quelles
solutions à apporter pour pour l'avenir
et qu'elle est dans tout
dans toute cette organisation le
distinguo vous faites entre préfets de
département préfet de zone et préfet de
région
ça c'est ma première question la
deuxième question je l' ai posé la
semaine dernière au ministre darmanin
concerne les protections des forces de
l'ordre vous avez évoqué les forces de
l'ordre en leur rendant hommage pour
tout le travail qu'ils ont effectué en
est faite durant durant cette période
difficile on a vu un certain moment que
des forces de l'ordre policiers ou autre
se se plaignait d'un manque de
protection et d'aller au front entre
guillemets démunis un désarmés à quel
moment a eu lieu cette tension sur les
protections de vos forces de l'ordre
d'abord un selon vous at elle eu lieu
deuxièmement à quel moment et comment
elle s'est résolue
ça c'est ma deuxième question la
troisième c'est sûr là les allées
contraventions les contrôles des
autorisations de sortie pendant
confinement vous avez dit ça a été
partout sur tout le territoire sans
exception c'est pas forcément les
notions que j'en avais lorsqu'on
regardait le reportage à la télévision
même suis très méfiant en effet de
chaîne de fou qui parfois ne disent pas
toujours la réalité mais néanmoins
est-ce que a posteriori et un retour
d'expérience ce dispositif était
perfectible ou s'il fallait revenir que
je ne souhaitons pas ici bien sûr
un confinement comment est-ce que ce
dispositif est perfectible sur les
mesures de contrôle aux frontières
je sais que j'ai des collègues qui sont
beaucoup plus pointu que moi sur cette
question ne leur laisserait poser posé
ce point de contrôle aux frontières et
dernier point vous avez évoqué la
cellule interministérielle de crise
lorsque en 2012
il y avait une circulaire qui disait
alouettes active est suffisamment en
amont pour lui permettre de monter en
puissance et d'exercer au mieux sa
capacité d'anticipation
alors je suppose que vous allez me dire
non parce qu'on n'a pas vu beaucoup
d'auto critique
nonobstant le respect qui faisait du
monsieur le ministre sur sur cette
période là mais est ce que justement
pour mieux anticiper elle n'aurait pas
dû être activé plus tôt selon vous et
non pas avoir une gestion au départ
exclusivement sanitaire ou excessivement
sanitaire merci aux ministres
si monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice sur le premier volet la
question du dialogue entre les ars et
les préfets je vais vous donner une
opinion personnelle parce que j'ai pas
d'étude ou de rapports précis sur ce
sujet mais ce que j'ai pu voir et que je
vivais déjà comme élu local en provence
alpes côte d'azur et que vous connaissez
c'est que le lien préfet de région ars
et globalement fluide
après il ya des personnalités je ne veux
pas donner l'exemple mais je sais qu'il
ya quelquefois des petites tensions qui
peuvent exister liés aux personnalités
et ce lien il est fluide parce que ils
vivent dans la même ville ils sont tous
les deux des représentants de
l'administration majeur ils ont
l'habitude de travailler ensemble de se
rencontrer et de dialoguer donc il ya
une fluidité presque naturel
là où c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
c'est au niveau des préfets de
département et drs parce que le niveau
d'organisation drs et très régionalisé
alors qu'on a un tel état des concentrés
dans les départements et que les moyens
qui sont pour les rs dans les
départements est à mon sens assez faible
dès lors qu'on est sur une approche très
régionalisé
ce qui fait qu'il n'ya pas forcément
cette culture du dialogue constant entre
le préfet de département d'un petit d'un
département avec ce son représentant de
la rs dans son département et que du
coup j'ai senti à plusieurs reprises qui
n'a pas la fluidité qu'on connaît
au niveau régional et ensuite il ya une
hétérogénéité qu'il y aussi aux
questions de personnes mais vous avez
raison il n'y a pas d'autorité de l'un
sur l'autre et donc du coup peut-être
que il faut rêver du centralisme
démocratique et ça avait des vertus qui
faisaient qu'à un moment donné il y
avait quelqu'un qui pour appuyer sur un
bouton et personne ne résistait à
l'instruction donnée donc on a pu avoir
des situations hétérogènes mais nous
aurons veiller avec l'olivier verront à
réunir très régulièrement à la fois les
préfets et les rs une à deux fois par
semaine on avait des réunions partager
et globalement j'ai vu en face de moi
des fonctionnaires qui avaient le sens
de l'état et la volonté de bien faire
mais des cultures qui sont très
différentes et d organisation spatiale
qui sont très différentes
je n'ai pas à me prononcer sur
l'organisation drs mais c'est vrai que
j'ai vu du côté du ministère de
l'intérieur que l'organisation de la
préfectorale au sens large a été
magistral dans la mise en oeuvre d'un
certain nombre de sujets ça veut pas
dire qu'il ya eu des erreurs qui a peu
eu des fautes voire des maladresses je
reviens pas sur la première question
mais je trouve que voilà quand on appuie
sur un bouton au ministère de
l'intérieur et que on se tourne vers les
préfets il ya un savoir faire une
expertise et je dis ça d'autant plus que
depuis une dizaine d'années les
préfectures ont été au delà des choix
qui ont été faits un moment donné de
régionaliser plutôt que de
départementaliser edouard philippe
halley souhaité que nous rôder parts il
monte à lisions l'état pour la proximité
nécessaire
je crois que c'est pas ici que je vais
tenter de vous convaincre de l'utilité
de renforcer les préfectures département
mais globalement les préfectures dans
notre pays on continue à perdre des
effectifs et chaque année ont perdu
beaucoup d'effectifs
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y aurait une
fragilité a continué cet affaiblissement
en termes de personnel et donc il faut
travailler sur ce jeu répond en partie à
votre question mais je crois qu'il ya à
la fois cette organisation spatiale et
des cultures qui sont assez différentes
sur les protections des forces de
l'ordre
c'est un sujet compliqué d'abord parce
que quand vous prenez un certain nombre
de décisions on peut toujours les lire
de deux façons différentes
pour préparer cette audition tout à
l'heure je relisais un article de
libération qui titre et castaner promène
900 mille masques aux policiers
christophe castaner assure que les
contrôles de police pour veiller au
respect du confinement se poursuivront
tout le week-end sur les chemins de
vacances dans les vacances république
pour s'assurer de ne pas être lâché par
les forces de l'ordre qui leur promet
900 mille masques en pleine pénurie de
masques pour le personnel soignant le
gouvernement fait donc le choix de
maintenir les contrôles au prix de 900
mille masques qui aurait pu être plus
utile ailleurs
je vous dis ça parce que je les relis
tout à l'heure mais je les lui tout à
l'heure à l'époque ça avait dû
m'échapper et on voit bien que sur ce
sujet toujours des arbitrages un peu
compliqué ce que je sais mais j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer ici enfin pas
devant votre commission mais devant le
sénat sur sur cela c'est que le
ministère de l'intérieur a tenté de
faire au mieux toujours et à partir du
13 mars nous avons distribué huit cent
dix mille masques qui étaient issus du
stock ministériel dont nous disposions
et la distribution s'est échelonnée
entre le 14 et le 23 mars selon des
différences et petit le 26 mars nous
avons renforcé encore de 300 mille
masques supplémentaires qui ont été
répartis entre la police nationale et la
préfecture de police et la gendarmerie
nationale le tout avec une doctrine qui
était celle de l'utilisation des masques
et qui n'était pas décidée par le
ministère de l'intérieur
nous avons veillé à ce que chaque lieu
susceptible d'être confronté à une
personne présentant des risques de co
vide on puisse avoir un équipement hi
media pour le personnel qui est
confronté à ce pas qu'il s'agisse de
l'accueil d'une caserne de l'accueil du
commissariat où des véhicules qui
intervenait sur le territoire pour que
chacun est un kit qui permettent donc
d'intervenir
progressivement nous avons renforcé cela
et 3 et 4 avril des commandes de 2.5
millions de masques en provenance de
chine ont été réceptionnés au 9 avril
on a ventilé 1 million 400 mille masques
supplémentaires est globalement au mois
d'avril ce sont 14 millions de masques
ont été distribués au sein des effectifs
de la police et de la gendarmerie
certains syndicats de police où presque
tous les syndicats de police voulait la
possibilité d'équiper et que ce soit
discrétion de chaque agent de s'équiper
ou pas de masque ça n'était pas conforme
à la doctrine nationale
nous avons organisé plusieurs rencontres
de type chsct
nous avons organisé une rencontre entre
le professeur salomon et des
organisations syndicales mon secrétaire
d'état laurent nunez étaient présents à
ce moment là et sur la doctrine d'emploi
des masques qui n'était pas décidée par
le ministre employeur il y avait un
désaccord entre les organisations
syndicales et nous et vous l'avez
entendu et puis à un moment un peu
sensible qui est sûre les masques de
type ffp2 qui sont les masques qui était
réservée au personnel soignant et
intervenante dans des hôpitaux
nous avions un stock d'un million 468
masques et j'ai fait le choix
d'appliquer la doctrine d'état qui
consistait à considérer que alors qu'on
était en tension pour le personnel
soignant
ce million quatre cent soixante mille
masques qui étaient répartis dans
différents lieux du territoire soit
confiée aux ars et aux hôpitaux
ça fait débat notamment de la part des
syndicats de police quand on sait quand
même que sur ce million quatre cent
soixante mille masques en fait y en
avait 100 milles qui relevait de la
police il y en avait un million deux qui
étaient dans les régions et qui relevait
de la gendarmerie
la gendarmerie a exécuté l'ordre que
j'ai donnée de dire ces masques doivent
aller en priorité personnel soignant
parce que ce sont les masques de type
ffp2 il ya eu des expressions de
désaccord de la part des organisations
syndicales de la police dont je rappelle
qu'elle avait cent mille masques
arrivent au sol de daya il y avait 200
milles qui revêt des qamis plus tôt
l'administration préfectorale qui
étaient directement concernées
en parallèle nous avons multiplié les
commandes et puis on a aussi passé des
commandes de paires de lunettes de
protection 61000 père avait été commandé
des moines menace 80 1 mille paires
supplémentaires au mois d'avril on avait
commandé aussi des visières en gros dans
la pénurie mondiale que nous
connaissions on a fait le choix de
tenter d'alimenter le plus largement
possible tous les moyens de protection
dont nous pouvons disposer enfin et donc
aux 26000 26 avril c'était 14 millions
de masques je vous le dis qu'ils avaient
été mobilisés et distribué qui avait été
dit vrai
et je sais que au mois de mai c'était 40
millions de masques donc on est quand
même sur des volumes qui sont assez
importants mais il n'y avait pas que ça
il y avait aussi la recommandation des
gestes barrières qui sont des sujets
importants et il y avait l'organisation
du temps de travail dans la police d'un
jeune amaury dans la gendarmerie pour
arriver à avoir une présence permanente
on a légèrement changé les cycles
horaires dans la journée dans la police
en a mis en place la réserve
opérationnelle qui faisait que les
policiers travailler une semaine sur
deux il avait en dehors
au delà il faisait leur rythme habituel
de travail mais la semaine suivante
était une semaine de pause qui me
permettait du coup de diminuer le risque
de maladie sur les policiers pour
encadre d'autres sujets prioritaires
pouvoir mobiliser une force
supplémentaire
en disant cela je précise que du coup
ils étaient moins confrontés une semaine
sur deux au risque de que vides
enfin et je parle sous le contrôle qui
vous réfère au sein du ministère de
l'intérieur
de mémoire on n'a heureusement pas eu de
décès de policiers ou de gendarmes
directement confronté au public dans le
cadre des opérations de contrôle qu'ils
soient imputables aux kovy de 19 mais ça
mérite d'être vérifiée mais voilà ce que
je voulais vous dire donc est ce que on
a répondu à la demande de tous d'avoir
des masques immédiatement non parce que
je rappelle qu'on avait une pénurie
mondiale qui d'ailleurs est touché même
la chine au début du phénomène où c'est
la france qui a envoyé des masques en
chine chacun s'en souvient on m'avait
posé la question de contraventions
contrôles partout partout avec les
moyens dont nous disposons mais ce que
je sais c'est qu'alors que la décision
était prise je crois de mémoire un lundi
de mettre en place le confinement pour
le mardi midi
notre organisation du ministère de
l'intérieur a répondu présent quasi
immédiatement dès le mardi on avait des
contrôles sans contravention qui étaient
organisées un peu partout sur le
territoire national
autant des gendarmes que des policiers
et dans tous les quartiers de france y
compris les quartiers les plus
difficiles je sais qu'il ya eu des
polémiques sur le fait que les quartiers
les plus difficiles de notre pays
n'était pas contre et ce n'est pas le
cas et j'avais donné des chiffres en
seine saint denis qui montait quant à
vos comptes au contraire un taux de
contrôle supérieur en seine saint denis
que dans d'autres
quartier ou dans d'autres départements
nationale est-ce qu'il est perfectible
oui mais il est d'autant plus
perfectible que je crois que nous avons
réussi la gestion du contrôle du
confinement parce que les français l'ont
voulu je m'explique
certes il y avait des contrôles je pense
que le contrôle est indispensable pour
appliquer des règles aussi strictes que
celles que nous connaissons mais c'est
aussi les français qui ont été les
premiers acteurs du confinement et qui
volontairement ont accepté de rentrer
dans la logique du confinement à la fois
parce qu'on avait dit attention il ya un
risque d'amande
mais aussi parce qu'ils avaient
conscience de l'importance si les
français avaient décidé de s'affranchir
du confinement
je crois que même avec toute la bonne
volonté et toutes nos forces nous
n'aurions pas être capacité d'atteindre
l'objectif tel qu'il a été réalisé
je le dis parce que évidemment il faut
la contrainte est un ancien ministre de
l'intérieur c'est l'importance de la
contrainte mais la réalité c'est que les
français ont été particulièrement
attentifs et au fur et à mesure des
semaines ils se sont un peu allégés des
contraintes et on a commencé à avoir des
gens qui utilisaient les dérogations
pour s'en affranchir un peu qui petit à
petit se sont adaptés ont levé le pied
mais si nous avons réussi le confinement
c'est parce que les français ont été les
premiers acteurs de l'effort du
confinement
nous reparlerons d'une mesure contrôles
aux frontières j'ai peu d'éléments sur
ce sujet soit décision d'ouverture de la
cic côté ministère de l'intérieur nous
on s'actionne quand on use actionne j'ai
rappelé qu'elle était placée sous
l'autorité du premier ministre
mais je voudrais pas laisser
l'impression que avant sa constitution
il ne s'était rien passé au ministère de
l'intérieur j'avais activé avec le
format plus réduit
mettez le début du mois de mars une
cellule nationale de suivi qui ne
s'appelait pas cic parce que je n'a pas
la capacité de l'activé personnellement
communiste de l'intérieur mais en gros
c'est un dispositif interne qui est dans
le classement de niveau 3 qui était le
même que celui qu'on avait activé au
moment des mouvements de jus des jeunes
quand on a connu des pressions les
samedis et donc la salle de gestion de
crise était ouverte des écrans la
coordination centrale était ouverte elle
est ensuite montée en puissance j'ai pas
eu le sentiment pour répondre à votre
question qu'on a eu des
dysfonctionnements entre les
instructions qui nous était donnée au
moment où il y avait seulement une
gestion avec tex force qui était
coordonnée par un préfet qui ensuite est
devenu le patron de la cic beauvau j'ai
pas eu le sentiment qu'ils aient des
instructions qui sont perdus entre la
rue de ségur et beauvau et quand il a
fallu travailler sur des sujets un peu
délicat comme par exemple la prévention
du risque de décès massifs avec la
réquisition de chambres froides et c'est
au fond on n'avait pas forcément besoin
que ce soit au sein de la section a
décidé le président de la république
considérait scène m'a dit faut faire
attention à ce qui s'est passé en
espagne ce qui s'est passé en italie ne
se produise pas chez nous on argué tel
système
donc on avait mis en place cette cellule
nationale de suivi au sein de la cic
beauvau même si elles étaient pas
formellement sous la forme de la série c
est ce qu il aurait fallu l'activé plus
tôt le ministre de l'intérieur qui la
vie au quotidien
ce sera adapté à la solution donnée est
ce que ça aurait été plus efficace je
suis objectivement pas capable de vous
le dire on a loupé des choses j'en suis
convaincu mais il est toujours facile de
savoir ce qu'on aurait pu faire une fois
qu on a l'information mois tous les
jeudis matin sont en capacité de gagner
au loto si je le tirage de mercredi soir
c'est le mercredi matin que c'est
beaucoup plus difficile au monde jouer
mais écoutez je vais poux
question qu'on suit châssis à porte voix
mais je dis je vais pouvoir passer aux
questions
votre rapporteur est impatiente des
questions de damien régnât merci
monsieur le président le ministre
merci pour votre témoignage et vos
éclaircissements sur ce qui s'est passé
au niveau du mystère l'intérieur la
question est courte et direct mais pour
éviter toute incompréhension est
possible j'ai déjà polémique totalement
loin de mes propos de mes pensées je
vais donner quelques précisions je suis
sénateur des français de l'étranger
depuis 24 ans à l'étranger et deux ans à
paris et maintenant
passionné de sécurité gestion de crise
et j'ai entre autres fait plusieurs
formations avec la fima aux états unis
je ne remets pas en cause l'ensemble de
des actions que vous avez menées et de
votre intervention pendant cette crise
cela étant notre commission a pour but
d'évaluer ce qui s'est passé est
d'essayer d'en tirer des leçons pour
l'avenir et j'ai une question une
question directe qui n'est ni polémique
ni une attaque personnelle contre vous
ou contre un ministre de la santé en
particulier mais devant cette crise
multi facettes qui devant un état
français que je que je redécouvre aussi
devant devant nos territoires nos notre
organisation
je vous pose la question à nouveau parce
que je suis reste sur ma faim sur votre
réponse à madame de roche tout à l'heure
pourquoi est ce que dans notre pays face
à cette crise à cette pandémie qu'on a
connu le ministère de l'intérieur n'a
pas été le leadership n'a pas été
j'allais dire la personne la personne
l'institution l'organisation qui a géré
au sens propre du terme cette crise bien
évidemment en s'appuyant sur les préfets
les maires
les élus bien évidemment en s'appuyant
sur l'aspect sanitaire puisque ça fait
partie de cette crise mais ça n'est pas
seulement un aspect sanitaire et donc je
reste quand même perplexe sur notre
organisation ici au sein du gouvernement
j'ai bien compris que c'était le premier
ministre j'ai bien compris que c'est le
président de la république décide mais
je voudrais avoir votre avis personnel
vous avez vécu cette crise directement
dans l'intérieur en tant que ministre
l'intérieur et donc d'une question très
courte et directe mais avec beaucoup de
l'enrobage jeu voilà voilà ma question
pourquoi le ministère l'intérieur n'est
pas apparu en tout cas vis-à-vis de
beaucoup de nos collègues ici mais
beaucoup de la population comme le
leader sur cette opération et que c'est
ce rôle est revenu au ministère de la
santé merci vous l'espériez merci le
président moi aussi une question courte
assez direct on est tous d'accord pour
dire que la pandémie a été d'une ampleur
inédite
monsieur le ministre vous avez parlé de
réponse rapide fermes adaptées
l'italie est un pays frontalier confine
sa population le 9 mars nous la
confinant le 17 mars
que ce passe-t-il entre les deux est ce
qu'il n'ya pas une forme de déni de la
part de nos dirigeants à ce moment là de
dire ce virus ne passera pas les
frontières
je vous remercie merci angèle près il
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
moi j'ai des trois petites questions
enfin petites questions très concrètes
alors on a parlé je suis de l'autre côté
voilà on a parlé de vol de masques et
bien évidemment pendant cette endémie
les vols de masques
c'était quelque chose de
difficile à envisager mais il fallait
résoudre ces affaires à ce qu'elles ont
été résolus c'est affaire de vol de
masques est ce qu'on a trouvé les
auteurs est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner
alors je sais pas si vous pouvez le
faire aujourd'hui mais les nombre de
masques qui ont été volés parce qu'on a
beaucoup parlé de ça donc voila moi
j'aurais voulu avoir des renseignements
là dessus après deuxième petite question
alors les contrôles les contrôles sur
les leurres du confinement
c'était pour éviter la propagation de la
pandémie mais il me semble où vous
demande si vous pouvez affirmer que tous
les gendarmes et les policiers qui ont
effectué des contrôles l'ont fait avec
des masques parce que sinon c'était être
le vecteur et toutes personnes
contrôlées étaient susceptibles d'être
porteuses de
deux sets de ce virus et donc un
gendarme qui faisait un contrôle et qui
n'avait ni gants ni masque qui faisait
baisser la vitre or moi j'ai vu aux
informations ça et qui prenait la
feuille pour regarder c'était ça allait
à l'encontre complet de ce qu'on voulait
faire
donc voilà et puis après vous n'avez pas
parlé du nombre de deux contraventions
de verbalisation qui ont eu lieu pendant
le confinement
moi j'avais cru comprendre mais vous
n'avez pas évoquer aujourd'hui moi je ne
donnerai pas le nombre je vous laisse le
soin de le faire que ce nombre était
avait une espèce de caractère
extravagant et vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le fait que ce confinement a été
réussie parce que les français se sont
bien plié mais quel sens cela at-il le
nombre de contraventions qui ont été
données nous les avons voté nous dans la
loi et c'était quand même 135 euros
alors que dans d'autres pays c'était une
contravention bien moindres notamment en
allemagne c'était que 35 euros donc cela
s'accompagnait et le législateur quand
il le fait il le fait parce que il faut
poser quelque chose mais après c'est
l'application sait comment est on le
fait et l'appliquer avec discernement
donc voilà je vous demande de nous
redire combien il ya eu de
contraventions et comme ma collègue est
ce qu'il y à une étude sur qui a été
verbalisé
dans qu'elle commence à se répartit sur
la carte et notamment sur les milieux
sociaux parce que c'était une amende
importante voit la mer merci donc je
vous propose monsieur ministre de
répondre à ces trois intervenants il en
reste 3 d'inscrits ensuite aller à la
première question pourquoi le ministère
de l'intérieur n'a pas pris la main moi
je pense que le musée interne n'est pas
compétent sur tout et que d'abord on
était sur une approche de crise
sanitaire avec la définition de process
qui étaient faits par des scientifique
par des experts du monde médical etc
c'est leur parole à eux qui ont guidé
les décisions du gouvernement et la
phase opérationnelle et la mise en
oeuvre et donc ceux qui sont les plus
aptes pour dialoguer avec le kursaal
scientifiques par exemple pour moi
relève du corps qui au lac du corps
médical
c'est plutôt le ministère de la santé
que le ministère de l'intérieur
ensuite j'ai pas le sentiment que si
nous avions déclencher si le premier
ministre avait décidé et je dis pas ça
pour me défausser mais je rappelle le
droit devant des sénateurs si le premier
titre avait décidé d'actionner la cic
j'ai pas le sentiment qu'ils auraient
des sujets que nous n'aurions pas
traités de la même façon et ça me permet
de répondre par exemple à la question de
savoir est ce qu'il ya eu un déni de
réalité en pensant que le virus ne
franchirais pas les frontières à aucun
moment mais la stratégie qui était celle
à ce moment là aussi de la phase 1 de la
phase de la phase iii et est déterminé
par les experts consisté à dire là où
dans une commune en un cluster qui se
créeront traite la question de la
commune et on ne met pas en place le
confinement on a beaucoup reproché à 6
baies tendaï par exemple d'avoir dit
s'agit pas de fermer les écoles etc
mais c'est un moment où la doctrine qui
avait été arrêté par le conseil
scientifique comme la doctrine
opérationnel prévoyez qu'on ne devait
pas mettre en place un confinement
nationale ça a évolué certains pays
avaient pris il ce choix là mais c'est
vrai que le regard qui nous étaient
portés a conduit et je n'ai pas décidé
cela mais là on perd je dis pas pour me
défausser mais j'en ai été témoin
notamment dans le cas des cds ain où les
recommandations qu'ils étaient donnés
ont été suivis et elle ne consistait pas
à prévoir un confinement ou une
fermeture de frontières
à la question de la gestion parlant des
frontières aériennes les mêmes experts
expliqué que la prise de température
compte tenu de la durée de
on n'est pas un club à sion enfin la
durée de développement du virus etc
ce n'était pas cohérent donc on a suivi
ça c'est toute la difficulté je vous le
dis avec mon expérience d'acteur public
donc je sois employés de collectivités
locales ou de cabinets ministériels que
je sois maire vice président de région
ou ministre et maintenant député c'est
la première fois de ma vie où j'ai été
amené à voir des décisions politiques
sur une base qui était une base donnée
comme scientifique qui évolue sans cesse
parce que la connaissance du virus à
évoluer sans cesse et que les
préconisations d'aujourd'hui n'étaient
pas les procurations de demain et
d'après demain toutes les décisions ont
été prises sur la base de préconisations
d'aujourd'hui est donc l n'amenez pas à
dire il faut fermer la frontière
italienne
parce que le virus pourrait passer non
c'était si le virus pas s'il peut passer
il est arrivé qu'ils passent dans sa
fille d'âge on savoir à ce moment là on
intervient sur le savoir et puis d'un
coup il ya une diffusion beaucoup plus
large
je ne reviendrai pas sur ses causes y
ait beaucoup d'études sur le sujet mais
c'est en fonction de cela dont il ya pas
eu de déni de réalité
mais la décision a été prise en fonction
d'éléments d'analysé scientifique qui
ont bougé et c'est le propre de la
science qui est confronté à une matière
qu'elle ne connaît pas et en fonction de
l'évolution de sa connaissance les
préconisations ont évolué on n'est pas
habitués à cela dans notre monde
politique où effectivement on a des
données via notre expérience on est
amené à prendre des décisions elles sont
bonnes ou pas bonne mais sur des données
stables
là non il ya une forme d'instabilité je
voulais une expérience personnelle pour
d'avoir vécu au coeur c'est quelque
chose sur lequel nous ne sommes pas
habitués
donc voilà pourquoi je ne peux pas vous
dire ça aurait été plus efficace une
ministère de l'intérieur prenez la main
et même si j'étais encore mills un
terrain je pense que j'aurai cette part
de doute dans ma réponse parce que je
n'en suis pas convaincu
après il ya plein de sujets qu'on aurait
peut-être mieux fait il ya plein de
sujets qu'on aurait certainement moins
bien fait je voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur le si je vous coupe
permettez moi puisque je vois des
réactions l'âge masqué très rapidement
très rapidement parce que en cas de en
cas de catastrophe écologique j'espère
que miss à l'intérieur se mobilisera que
ça ne restera pas qu'entre les mains du
missel de lorient dans ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que
je maintiens que c'est une crise qui est
qui va au delà de simplement une crise
sanitaire qu'aujourd'hui me sers de la
santé prend des décisions qui relèvent
qu'ils relèveraient peut-être du
ministère des affaires étrangères j'en
parle en connaissance de cause et qui
vont à l'encontre même des
recommandations du ministère des
affaires étrangères quelquefois donc je
me pose la question à nouveau encore une
fois c'est pas une attaque ni personnel
ni de personne mais sur la structure de
ce face à des crises le rôle du
ministère de l'intérieur dans notre pays
aurait enfin je pense aujourd'hui aurait
dû être vraiment la locomotive c'est
vous qui avez mis c'est formulaire de
s'exaucer vous qui avez mis
la gendarmerie la police sur les routes
c'est vous qui avait ses relations
privilégiées avec nos préfets et avec
nos régions donc je vois je vous demande
pas si le président voulait où vous
sollicitez voix devant votre avis
personnel sur est ce que une crise
pandémique ce qui pourrait survenir à
nouveau pourrait changer éventuellement
après cette expérience la base du retour
de votre expérience
merci merci et céline bonnier
merci de votre réponse à ses ministres
mais moi ce n'était pas de dire à partir
du moment où nos voisins confine ce qui
est une décision politique très forte
la france aurait dû confiner en même
temps mais dans le temps dans ce laps de
temps entre le confinement nos voisins
italiens est le nôtre nous vivions quasi
normalement il y avait des réunions
publiques
nous avions voté il aurait pu y avoir
une période de transition où on ouvrait
tout les parapluies en prenaient les
précautions les plus élémentaires
en attendant de voir si on a les
confiner c'est ça c'était ça le sens de
ma question
non mais oui bien sûr il gémit niveau
dire monsieur le président avec des
masques et franchement pour aller plus
loin avec un dax en moi je vous provoque
un peu mais n'hésitons pas à dire quand
même droit fut un vaccin
j'ai rappelé qu' il y avait une pénurie
mondiale de masques alors certes on peut
négliger cette dimension là on peut
oublier que la chine qui était le
premier pays confronté directement à ce
virus avec des éléments statistiques
qu'on ne connaît pas forcément été lui
aussi en pénurie de masques et donc on
peut négliger sahara et continue à dire
des masses des masques mais je vous
réponds bien sûr le président que nano
ou pas fait pour trouver un virus
on est fin septembre un axe 1 donc voilà
je pense que il faut aussi accepter que
les principes de réalité qui font qu'il
n'ya pas de baguette magique
non mais arrêtez moi de vous dire deux
pays ont réagi différemment quand même
hein donc il y avait des volontés ils
ont trouvé plus rapidement nous quand
même hein donc écouter à vers l'un quand
nous avions bien ce papa de complaisance
par rapport à ça je dirais comme je
n'aurai aucune monsieur le président
j'ai quelques indicateurs notamment sur
les masques j'ai souvenir que quand nous
avions des masques dans notre pays ils
n'y allaient pas dans la capitale
allemande et on a souvent voulu comparer
aussi que quand on regarde la presse
internationale
qui commentent et peut-être que ça et
clara aussi les travaux de commissions
ce qui s'est passé dans notre pays on
n'a pas à rougir de ce qui s'est passé
dans notre pays alors on peut se
flageller et penser que tout est mieux
ailleurs
même quand j'observe aujourd'hui la
situation et les bilans je pense que
tout n'est pas mieux ailleurs
après je ne vous dis pas qu'on a tous
bien fait et je ne pense pas que le
ministère de l'intérieur side avait été
et je rebondis à la dernière remarque
dans la capacité de définir la doctrine
de qualité le sujet dont on parle c'est
celui de la doctrine face au virus
je le dis je pense que le ministère de
l'intérieur est un ministère
extraordinaire de compétence c'est un
mystère d'action je pense que le
mystérieux terre n'était pas en capacité
de définir la doctrine de lutte contre
le virus et que c'était sa relevé
d'autres instances plus interministériel
et en particulier du ministère de la
santé de la solidarité parce que je n'ai
jamais vu aucun préfet aucun directeur
d'administration centrale me dire voilà
la bonne façon dont on doit traiter 1
kloster et c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas
cette compétence dans le sujet et donc
je ne critique pas le ministère de
l'intérieur je vous dis je pense que
c'est un des ministères les plus
puissants de notre pays pour mettre en
oeuvre de façon opérationnelle ou pour
gérer des crises de façon extraordinaire
mais je vous pouvez vous donner mille
exemples mais sur la définition de la
doctrine doctrine d'organisation et de
lutte contre la pandémie
ils l'exécutent des orientations il
n'est pas le mieux à même de décider des
orientations de lutte contre ce sujet là
pour ça qu'ils aient un travail
interministériel mais ce que je sais
c'est que toutes les demandes qui ont
été faites à ce ministère ce mini star a
répondu globalement bien à toutes les
demandes qui était fait
est-ce qu'on a passé les bonnes
commandes je ne sais pas c'est là où le
débat est plus ouvert sur les questions
du nombre de vols de masques
je ne suis pas en capacité de vous
répondre aujourd'hui je pense que les
services du ministère de l'intérieur
sont capables de répondre et sur les
affaires résolues
là aussi je pense que seul le ministère
de l'intérieur et le ministère de la
justice sont en capacité de vous
répondre sur l'équipement de masse que
je répondu précisément
à cette question là et nous n'avions pas
parce que c'était pas la doctrine
nationale prévu que tous les policiers
et tous les gendarmes dès le début de la
diffusion du kobus dans d'autres pays
soient équipés en permanence de masques
comme nous le sommes aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le son la doctrine a changé
et la doctrine en fait c'est celle que
nous avons appliqué pour l'ensemble des
ministères la doctrine était priorité
aux personnels soignants dans un premier
temps pour l'équipement en permanence de
masquer ce n'était pas le cas pour les
autres administrations je vous le dis le
ministère de l'intérieur est
certainement celui qui a fait en sorte
que ces personnels soit en fonction de
la progression de la disponibilité des
masques dans notre pays le plus vite
possible
équipés pour assurer cela le nombre de
verbalisations j'ai plus de chiffres
exacts c'est pas dans mes archives et je
ne suis pas parti avec les archives du
ministère de l'intérieur je les ai mis à
disposition du service des archives mais
je crois qu'on était à plus de 1 million
et à plus de 20 millions de contrôles
qui était organisée mais je mets cela
entre parenthèses mais j'ai rendu public
ces chiffres et le ministère de
l'intérieur pourra vous les communiquer
à l'unité près parce que ce qu'on a un
système de reporting sur le nombre de
contrôles chaque unité fait remonter à
son échelon supérieur et ça remonte
presque quotidiennement est on arrivé à
comptabiliser jour par jour le nombre de
contrôles qui est effet ramené à la
population s'était pas énorme et ramener
aux policiers présents sur le terreau
est en moyenne entre 5 et 10 contrôle
par jour c'est ça aussi les proportions
dans lesquelles nous étions mais c'est
un nombre significatif alors je ne sais
pas si une étude a été menée sur le qui
a été verbalisée mais par contre on peut
avoir une approche territoriale ce que
je disais sur la seine saint denis
j'avais donné ces chiffres là donc on
peut les retrouver
qui du coup sont un indicateur mais ne
sont pas justes je peux faire un truc
l'air sur le sujet non on était plutôt
sur cinq à dix contrôles par jour mais
ramené au nombre de policiers gendarmes
358 le ramener sur l'ensemble du
territoire national
donc ça n'a pas de sens vous avez raison
dans votre lit la précision je passe aux
questions suivantes
olivier paccaud ainsi monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre dans le
prolongement des interventions des
sénatrices desrochers préville je me
permets même si vous avez en partie
répondu mais je me permets de revenir à
cette période pendant laquelle au début
du confinement donc les forces de
l'ordre de l'ordre pardon en france on
devrait sans masque alors vous avez dit
qu' il y avait la même problématique
dans d'autres pays vous avez cité
l'allemagne mais je pense sincèrement
que l'immense majorité de vos collègues
entre guillemets bénéficier de masse
qu'on voyait tous les soirs les images
en inde en chine un peu partout les
forces de l'ordre étaient masqués et je
me souviens mois d'image qui va qu'il
m'avait marqué à la frontière espagnole
on avait les policiers français alors y
avait des douaniers y avait aussi des
policiers qui n'étaient pas masqués et
qui étaient très mécontents en montrant
leurs collègues de l'autre côté de la
frontière la guardia civil qui elle
étaient masquées
alors ça pose vraiment question bon vous
l'avez vous avez parlé de doctrine vous
avez revendiqué le fait de reverser
c'était le terme de laurent nunez 1
million 400 mille masques ffp2 aux ars
mais vous avez mis en danger vos hommes
vous avez mis en danger vos hommes vous
avez mis en danger et madame préville
l'a aussi fait remarquer les personnes
qui ont été contrôlées à qui on donnait
où on prenait un papier sans qu'il y ait
de protection il faut en être conscient
je sais pas si c'était la bonne doctrine
mais c'est à fait vous avez dit tout à
l'heure vous n'en est pas sûre mais qui
a une morts parmi les forces de l'ordre
dû au corps d'un virus il semblerait que
dans le cadre de contrôles il ya eu à ma
connaissance trois morts décoratrice
dans le service pour des gens qui
n'étaient pas en responsabilité de
terrain qui n'était pas sur le contrôle
suivant moi j'ai fini sans merci
mais effectivement je je suis content de
votre précieux parce que moi j'avais
entendu qu'il y avait quand même des
morts parmi les forces de l'ordre
mais justement avez-vous des
statistiques précises concernant les
forces de l'ordre qui ont été touchés
qui ont été plus ou moins fortement
touchés dans mon département dans mon
canton le canton de mouy il ya deux
gendarmes mais il y en a une qui a été
fermée carrément fermé ce qui est
rarissime
parce qu'il y avait une dizaine de
gendarmes qui était sur le flanc
dernière toute petite question vos
stocks de masques ont ils été
reconstituée pour doter les forces de
l'ordre merci vic michel meunier moi
c'est dans une question dans le cadre de
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
très vite au moment du confinement la
garde des sceaux a précisé par
circulaire les mesures apportées pour
l'éviction du conjoint violent du
domicile
donc j'avais une question qu'elles ont
été
les suites que vous avez donné les
consignes que vous avez donnée aux
forces de l'ordre est ce que vous avez
un bilan chiffré de ces éloignements
deux conjoints violents
et est ce que c'est des sujets qui
faisait partie de la fameuse cellule
interministérielle passé ici merci
monsieur le premier ministre
merci victoire au sema bien ce monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre j'ai
bien compris que vous étiez quelque part
tributaire de l'avis du conseiller
scientifique
le président le président le professeur
delfraissy nous disait ici qui les
unités un avis est que la décision était
politique
donc là il ya après il y avait les
ordonnances évidemment donc là vous
prenez de répondre en quelque sorte pour
dire que vous étiez quand même dans
cette logique là bon je pense que vous
auriez pu faire un certain nombre de
préconisations
alors pour ce qui concerne les outre-mer
ma collègue madame céline terminé vous
les espionner a évoqué les zones
frontalières mais moi je vous dois te
parler d outre-mer alors c'est fait vous
n'êtes plus ministre
mais si vous deviez su gérer un certain
nombre de préconisations concernant les
frontières par rapport à la guyane déjà
parce que là c'était particulier et on a
vu les rebonds mais aussi par rapport à
saint martin parce que la situation
était encore délicate jusqu'à il ya
quelques jours donc vous étiez
évidemment ministre quand il ya eu les
décisions particulières et là encore la
préfète parce que vous avez travaillez
beaucoup avec les préfets mais la
préfète avait mis en place un système
pour protéger la partie française mais
si on territoire comme saint martin ce
n'est pas évident les personnes qui
depuis dix ans maria ont dû aller
habiter de l'autre côté de la frontière
qui est une frontière qui est toujours
permis à bhl ont eu récemment des
difficultés pour aller travailler et les
élèves ont eu aussi des difficultés vont
aller à l'école tout simplement parce
qu'ils ont été hébergés depuis les les
aura quand ils ont marre il ya de
l'autre côté de la frontière dont une
frontières provisoires avaient été mises
et il a fallu que ce soit
la population mais aussi le président de
la collectivité du côté français qui
s'émeuvent pour que l'on fait on trouve
des solutions alors si vous avez des
suggestions parce que maintenant des
plans 70 situation de haut niveau du
ministère des suggestions à faire par
rapport à ce que vous avez mis en place
au moment où vous étiez là qu'auriez
vous proposez à votre successeur merci
très bien merci monsieur le ministre
c'est à vous merci monsieur le président
je vais redire ce que j'ai dit monsieur
paco j'ai bien entendu le côté mes
hommes je les ai mis en danger etc
vous savez je crois que quand vous êtes
mise intérieur vous mettez les policiers
les gendarmes si je prends votre logique
en danger permanent parce qu'ils sont
dans un monde qui est par nature hostile
et il s'engage quel que soit le style it
et du monde auxquelles ils doivent faire
face
et donc on pourra toujours cherché à
mettre en cause un ministre en
responsabilité sur ces sujets la suite
un ministre il applique des doctrines de
protection de ses personnels et donc je
vais être extrêmement clair plus que
m'interroger une nouvelle fois sur ce
sujet je me suis exprimé à plusieurs
reprises ici mais vraiment vous dire que
la première contrainte que nous savions
et y lier à cette disposition de masques
au niveau national et donc nous avons
appliqué mais vraiment de la façon la
plus stricte toutes les consignes qui
nous était donné les consignes que nous
étonner c'était une doctrine d'emploi et
cette doctrine d'emploi elle a évolué en
fonction de la circulation du virus sur
le territoire national mais je le redis
j'ai veillé non pas pour me
déresponsabiliser mais parce que je
trouve que la mise en cause est toujours
facile et que c'est bien d'avoir cette
capacité à être mise en cause mais je
vais vous dire ce que j'ai fait en
responsabilité je veillais dans le
strict de la doctrine gouvernementale
d'utilisation de masse telles qu'elles
étaient définis en prenant en compte le
stock opérationnelle du ministère de
faire en sorte à ce que nous ayons des
kits de protection disponible dans tous
les véhicules de patrouille ou
d'interventions auprès de ceux qui sont
chargés de recevoir le public dans les
commissariats mais aussi dans les
commissaires dans les brigades de
gendarmerie ou les guichets des
préfectures et il a été précisé c'était
la doctrine que les masques devait être
portée en cas de cons
acte avec une personne présentant ou des
symptômes ducobu 19 ou dans des cas de
figure présentant un risque important de
cette nature cette doctrine avait été
présenté au chsct exceptionnel du 9 mars
par le secrétaire général du ministère
elle a d'ailleurs été présidée par une
inscription du directeur général de la
police nationale le 13 mars et des
consignes du directeur général d'aj en
allemagne nationale du 16 et du 27 mars
le 23 mars pour répondre aux
interrogations qui résultait de la
progression de la diffusion de ce virus
j'ai souhaité qu'une réunion se tienne
avec les organisations syndicales de la
police nationale en lien d'ailleurs avec
la gendarmerie nationale et le directeur
général de la santé le professeur
salomon suite sur la dotation en
équipements les stocks disponibles je
vais donner un certain nombre de
chiffres
le 13 mars 1810 mille masques qui
étaient issus du stock mistral dont nous
disposions 300 mille masques
supplémentaires essaie de monter en
puissance jusqu'à 14 millions de masques
au mois d'avril sur cela donc à la
question de savoir si tous les policiers
étaient équipés de masques qu'ils
pouvaient les changer toutes les quatre
heures
quelle que soit leur activité la réponse
effectivement non peut-être que nous
aurions pu prendre la décision de dire
aux policiers aux gendarmes de notre
pays de rester chez eux de ne plus
sortir de ne plus aller sur le terrain
j'ai pris ma part de responsabilité
effectivement elle est difficile mais
j'ai choisi d'être ministre de
l'intérieur donc je les assume
pleinement
j'ai pris ma part de responsabilité pour
appliquer cette doctrine là au vu des
éléments qui étaient communiqués sur la
façon dont on devait gérer le virus et
il est beaucoup plus facile de le
commenter
quelques mois après d'imaginer ceux
qu'on aurait pu faire il ya plein de
sujets sur lequel dans ma vie j'aurais
pris des décisions différentes mais j'ai
pris des décisions avec un éclairage
données pour répondre madame la
sénatrice au fait que c'est
effectivement les scientifiques vous
donne un avis ensuite c'est des
décisions politiques
elle était prise dans le cadre du cdsn
avec la volonté de suivre le regard
scientifique mais les décisions
politiques qui sont prises nous devons
les assumer et je les assume tout
pour ce qui me concerne en fonction des
éclairages et j'assume d'ailleurs même
si je n'étais pas en capacité de décider
parce que ça relève du président et du
premier ministre mais j'assume
pleinement la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle des décisions qui ont été
prises dans ce cadre là parce que ce
sont des décisions politiques sur
laquelle nous devons agir je reviendrai
sur la gestion des frontières même si
c'est un sujet compliqué pour moi
mais pour monsieur paco vous dirai ce
que les stocks utiles ont été
reconstitués il faut demander au
ministre de l'intérieur je suis bien
incapable de vous répondre
savoir si aujourd'hui des stocks du
ministère de l'intérieur ont été
reconstitués je ne suis plus ministre de
l'intérieur ovi juillet mais ce que je
sais c'est que nous avions commandé plus
de 100 millions de masques pour la
police la gendarmerie et la préfectorale
dans notre pays et que je crois vraiment
en dehors du ministère de la santé que
le ministère de l'intérieur à celui qui
a été le plus agile pour faire en sorte
de garantir l'équipe au maximum de ces
forces d'action pas seulement de ses
forces de sécurité intérieure sur la
question des violences conjugales
je crois que le ministère et les
impulser personnellement à tenter de
répondre à ces situations dramatiques
que nous connaissons hélas dans notre
quotidien mais que nous connaissions en
particulier du fait du confinement et
des violences sur lesquelles on pouvait
avoir
l'incapacité de plier une alerte sur ce
sujet là et je crois que le ministère
est à l'initiative d'un certain nombre
de choses
je pense par exemple à l'accord qui
était donné par l'ordre national des
pharmaciens sur les alertes dans les
pharmacies un jour j'ai vu que ça se
pratique et en espagne voyez des fois on
n'a pas d'idée on peut les pompes et
ailleurs et donc j'ai appelé
personnellement la présidente de l'ordre
national des pharmaciens pour lui dire
voilà en espagne se passe ça est-ce que
vous avez la capacité de faire passer le
message et on tombe de faire ça dans
toutes les pharmacies de france
elle m'a répondu banco ensuite nous
avons élargi tous les moyens possible de
donner l'alerté
la vraie difficulté c'est que quand vous
êtes confiné avec un conjoint violent
pouvait pas forcément téléphoner alors
on a mis en place et c'était une
suggestion de laurent wauquiez qui me
l'avait fait un numéro par texto pour
donner l'alertent par texte 11 ans si
j'ai un téléphone je peux aller me
cacher aux toilettes et je peux envoyer
un texto
j'ai eu cette idée dans un courrier
donné par laurent wauquiez et donc gelé
mise en oeuvre de la même façon on s'est
dit ça peut être par internet sur les
tchats et donc on a ouvert un dispositif
24 heures sur 24 pour donner l alerte et
sans même que je le demande aux
policiers et aux gendarmes ils sont
venus me voir pendant la gestion de
crise en disant on va après on va faire
des appels d'initiative c'est à dire que
on connaît des situations familiales qui
n'ont
abouti un suivi judiciaire mais dans
lequel on pourrait craindre qu'ils aient
des problèmes et donc ils zappent les
deux mêmes dans la famille il ya au son
de la voix parce qu'ils sont formés pour
parce qu'ils ont cette capacité il
intervenait il sentait qu'il y avait un
problème et donc ils passent et
d'initiative est-ce qu'on a réglé tous
les problèmes
évidemment non mais je vais vous dire
qu'ils ont été particulièrement mobilisé
sur ces sujets pour faire en sorte que
chaque fois que c'était possible en lien
évidemment avec la misère justice avec
marlène schiappa qui suivait ces
dossiers avec aussi aurélien taquet sur
adrien attaqué sur les menaces sur les
enfants parce qu'on a élargit aussi nos
dispositifs parce qu'on sait bien que
dans ce lieu fermé le pire est toujours
possible et donc vraiment ils ont été
très actifs sur ce jeu dit il
même si j'ai pu impulser moi même si je
crois qu'ils avaient conscience de
l'enjeu majeur sur lequel il fallait
porter cette vision c'est ils ont fait
des choses assez remarquable mais hélas
ils n'ont pas pu prévenir toutes les
situations de violence intrafamiliale
que nous connaissons que ce soit sur le
conjoint ou que ce soit sur sur les
enfants sur votre question madame jasmin
je ne peux pas vous répondre aujourd'hui
sur la gestion des frontières parce que
ce qu'on voit c'est effectivement
notamment sur les outre-mer on a pris
des mesures assez drastiques pour
limiter l'accès dans les outre mer et
que c'était objectivement la meilleure
façon de faire il ya un territoire
d'outre-mer qui a été totalement
préservé du virus parce que c'est wallis
et futuna parce qu'effectivement on a
coupé la totalité de destination mais
c'est extrêmement lourd à gérer
on l'a connue avec mayotte par exemple
où on a eu un développement du virus
mais dès lors qu'on supprimer toutes les
lignes d'accès se poser la question des
transports sanitaires donc il a fallu
rétablir des transports sanitaires entre
mayotte et la réunion et la même façon
on a eu le problème des étudiants des
enfants des familles qui ne pouvaient
pas rentrer chez eux parce qu'on avait
plus de fret
on avait plus de vols et donc du coup on
avait un problème et en avait c'est pour
ça que j'ai parlé fret aussi un problème
de fret
parce que du coup comme y avait plus de
vols réguliers on met tout ça est
extrêmement délicat mais il est vrai que
pour les outremers contenu globalement
du sous-équipement que nous avons en
matière de capacité en réanimation
il a fallu projeter des unités je crois
que vous avez eu madame parlais tout à
l'heure les unités militaires
quelquefois il a fallu organiser des
vols evasan pour faire le transport de
malades mais il a fallu surtout tenter
de prévenir au maximum le développement
du virus parce qu'on savait que les
capacités n'était pas forcément dans les
moyens de faire face le seul conseil que
je donnerais c'est effectivement celui
de limiter au maximum tout entrer
nouvelles sur ces territoires mais sur
la guyane là on sait qu'on a une autre
dimension de difficulté qui est que
contrôler la totalité des frontières de
la guyane c'est pas la peine que je
commente on sait la limite du système
merci monsieur le ministre ya pas
d'autres questions juste vous rassurer
monsieur le ministre
dans cette commission denquête on ne
commande pas l'histoire on ne la réécrit
pas simplement on essaye justement
humblement de l'analyser merci à toutes
et tous
merci